[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen Freitagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen willkommen zu den
Nachrichten
rudizana hat Fußball für sie ja hallo
schönen guten Abend
der russische Präsident hat heute
versucht Fakten zu schaffen
eine Unterschrift gegen das Völkerrecht
Putin annektiert ukrainische
Staatsgebiet lässt sich feiern und
beschwört die russische Nation
die Realität des Krieges wieder werden
Zivilisten zu opfern die Ukrainer
sprechen von einem russischen
Raketenangriff
und Trümmer so weit das Auge reicht in
Florida inspizieren die Menschen das was
der Hurrikan Ian ihn gelassen hat
[Musik]
gut sieben Monate nach dem russischen
Angriff auf die Ukraine hat cremesev
Putin heute vier ukrainische Gebiete
annektiert Europäische Union NATO und
USA Verurteilten den Schritt als
rechtswidrig
am Nachmittag besiegelte Putin die
Aufnahme der ukrainischen Region luhans
Don jetzt saporicia und hassson in die
Russische Föderation Gebiete die nur zum
Teil unter russischer Kontrolle stehen
hier orange markiert die genauen Grenzen
seien noch zu klären hieß es aus dem
Kreml Nina nibagger berichtet
die gesamte Polit-Elite ist im Kreml
versammelt Putins Auftritt perfekt
inszeniert mit gut 15 Minuten Verspätung
betritt der russische Präsident die
Bühne und verkündet offiziell
die Menschen in luhans tun jetzt kerson
und saporicia werden unsere Bürger für
immer
die Botschaft vor allem ans eigene Volk
ich habe alles im Griff wir werden
siegen vermeintlich streckt Putin die
Hand sogar für Verhandlungen aus zu
seinen Bedingungen
wir rufen das kiefer-regime dazu auf das
Feuer sofort zu stoppen und zum
Verhandlungstisch zurückzukommen wir
sind bereit das haben wir immer wieder
betont aber wir werden die Entscheidung
der Menschen in luhansk Donezk saporisha
und reason nicht diskutieren sie haben
sich entschieden Russland wird sie nicht
im Stich lassen mit der Unterzeichnung
der anschlussverträge will Putin Fakten
schaffen die auf den Straßen Moskaus
längst nicht jeder gut findet russland
steht unter Druck seit der
teilmobil-machung verlassen
hunderttausende das Land i think it es
ist ein totales Desaster nicht nur für
die Ukraine auch für Russland
doch rund um den Roten Platz trifft man
heute nur Putins Anhänger die russische
Welt wird sich ausdehnen auf die ganze
Welt finden Sie sich damit ab
Herrschaften
seit dem frühen Abend ist die
propaganda-show in vollem Gange
patriotische Künstler Heizen der Menge
ein der Hauptact Putin persönlich er
rechtfertigt noch einmal die Annexion
die moderne Ukraine wurde von Russland
geschaffen russland hat erhebliche
historische Gebiete übergeben zusammen
mit der Bevölkerung bei dem Zerfall der
Sowjetunion ist genau das gleiche
passiert die Eliten haben alles unter
sich beschlossen Millionen von einfachen
Bürgern wurden von keinem gefragt
Putin lässt sich heute feiern auch wenn
viele im Land der Meinung sind dass es
keinen Grund zum Feiern gibt
[Musik]
gehen wir zu unseren Korrespondenten in
Russland und der Ukraine als erstes nach
Moskau zu ihnen Christian sem hinter
ihnen fand er bis eben noch diese
Inszenierung statt was will der
russische Präsident Putin erreichen
ja die große patriotismus-show hier
hinter mir auf dem Roten Platz die so
vor 15 Minuten zu Ende gegangen wladimir
Putin hat heute versucht das russische
Volk davon überzeugen dass das dass der
Anschluss dieser ukrainischen Gebiete
dass das ein großer historischer Sieg
für Russland ist und hier wurde der
Patriotismus beschworen das hat er
versucht ob das Volk das so annehmen
wird das werden wir sehen und sein
vermeintliches Angebot für neue
Friedensgespräche die darf man nicht
ernst nehmen denn gleichzeitig sagt
Putin dass diese neuen Gebiete Gebiete
nicht Teil solcher Friedensverhandlungen
sein könnten also wladimir Putin hat
heute mit dem Anschluss dieser Gebiete
hat der Fakten geschaffen und Russland
ist bereit diese Gebiete auch bis zum
Ende zu verteidigen blicken wir mal nach
Harke zu torgebode Torge wie wird in der
Ukraine auf die Annektion reagiert
also vielleicht zunächst einmal die
offiziellen Reaktion Präsident selensky
hatte wir heute den Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat einberufen und im
Anschluss an dieser Sitzung wurde ein
Dokument unterzeichnet das den Antrag
waren in beschleunigten nato-beitrag
stellt außerdem hat Präsident silence
noch einmal betont solange Wladimir
Putin präsent von Russland ist wird es
keine Friedensverhandlungen zwischen Kia
von Moskau geben wenn man mit den
Menschen spricht da gibt es eigentlich
eine ganze Bandbreite von Reaktionen
Emotionen das geht von Wut über Ärger da
bis hin zu trotz nach dem Motto jetzt
erst recht wir werden uns unser Land
zurückholen wenn man allerdings näher an
die frontgebiete kommt das ist so meine
Erfahrung der letzten Tage dann mischt
sich doch auch eine ganz gehörige
Portion Angst mit unter diese Gefühle
und das ist die Angst davor dass dieser
Konflikt weiter eskalieren könnte und
wenn man sich anschaut wie Kia von
Moskau gerade agieren da muss man
wirklich zugeben dass diese Angst nicht
ganz unberechtigt ist Dankeschön für
diese Einschätzung TOGGO Bode und
Christian sem
die Reaktion aus dem Westen auf die
gebietsameignung sind deutlich die USA
verhängen weitere Sanktionen gegen
Russland außerdem drohten sie zusammen
mit den G7 Partnerländern jenen
Einzelpersonen Organisation und Staaten
Konsequenzen an die die russischen
annektionspläne politisch oder
wirtschaftlich unterstützen
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg nannte
die Annektion die größte Eskalation seit
Beginn des Krieges um mehr dazu können
Sie in einem zdf-spezial sehen russische
Annektion Eskalation im Ukraine Krieg
direkt nach unseren heute Nachrichten
schauen wir auf die militärische Lage in
den von Russland beanspruchten Gebieten
am Tag der feierlichen Annektion läuft
es dort für die russische Armee offenbar
nicht gut die Ukrainer melden neue
Erfolge unter anderem einen größeren
Vorstoß im Donbass christoph desterell
hat mehr
ein paar bildschnipsel nur aber
zich-wach geteilt im Netz angeblich der
Beweis russische Soldaten fliehen beim
Kampf um lemanen in Panik eine Prüfung
des Videos ergibt zwar dass es 30
Kilometer südlich der Stadt aufgenommen
wurde gleichzeitig bestätigen selbst
Kreml Treue militärblogger etwa der
telegrammkanal Riva um Mitternacht
gelang es den Streitkräften der Ukraine
Lemans tatsächlich in einen Kessel
einzuschließen die Karte lässt die
Verzweiflung der wohl 5000 festsitzenden
russischen Soldaten an ihre letzte
versorgungs- und Fluchtroute südlich vom
Ort saritschne zu sehen wird immer
wieder von den Ukrainern beschossen etwa
von jampil aus heute morgen erst
zurückerobert samt Beleg für die Kamera
Leute Jan pill gehört uns
noch andere Videos tauchen im Netz auf
gut ausgerüstet ukrainische Soldaten
sind zu sehen vorbei an verlassenen
Panzern und toten Besatzern ziehen sie
angeblich den Ring um Lehmann noch enger
das Gebiet wäre für die Truppen ein
perfekter Brückenkopf für einen
möglichen Vormarsch Richtung Johannes
derweil gut 300 Kilometer weiter
südwestlich in der unbesetzten Stadt
saporisha eine Tragödie für die
ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung aus der
Luft treffen Bomben einen wartenden
Autokonvoi die erste schlug vorne ein
dann eine zweite in der Mitte und dann
noch eine dritte am Ende dazwischen
immer gut 20 Minuten
mindestens 23 Menschen sterben
eigentlich hätten sie Verwandte aus den
besetzten Gebieten holen und in
Sicherheit bringen wollen sagt der
Gouverneur und klagt Russland an dort
aber weißt man jede Schuld zurück in
Wirklichkeit hätte die Ukraine ihre
eigenen Leute beschossen weil die auf
jetzt wieder russischen Boden hätten
übersiedeln wollen
durch den ukraine-krieg sind die
Energiepreise ja zurzeit sehr hoch die
eu-ministerin und Minister zuständig für
Energie haben sich da heute bei einem
Sondertreffen auf einen Notfallpaket
geeinigt um VerbraucherInnen zu
entlasten so sollen europaweit hohe
Gewinne von Stromkonzern abgeschöpft
werden Streit dagegen über den Vorschlag
nicht mehr als einen bestimmten Preis
für Gasimporte zu bezahlen aus Brüssel
Isabel Schäfers
für die eu-energieminister ist derzeit
jede Sitzung eine Krisensitzung der
Druck die Strom- und Gaspreise vor dem
Winter zu senken ist riesig deshalb
einigten sich die Minister darauf
übermäßige Gewinne von
Energieunternehmen abzuschöpfen die
entstehen weil der Strompreis in Europa
derzeit vom teuren Gas bestimmt wird die
Produktion von Strom etwa aus
erneuerbaren Energiequellen oder aus
Atomkraft ist wesentlich günstiger die
dadurch entstehenden übergewinne sollen
nun begrenzt werden auf welche Höhe kann
flexibel von den Mitgliedstaaten
angepasst werden alles darüber hinaus
wird vom Staat abgeschöpft um Haushalte
und Firmen zu entlasten
auch Gas und Ölkonzerne sollen Teile
ihrer diesjährigen übergewinner abgeben
gut ein Drittel trotzdem es ist weder
sinnvoll noch möglich die vollen Kosten
die jetzt in diesem Jahr auf die
Verbrauchern und die Verbraucher und die
Unternehmen zugekommen sind zu nehmen
das heißt wir brauchen weiter
Energiespar Anstrengungen und es wird
auch nicht so sein dass die gesamte Last
die auf Deutschland gekommen ist und auf
Europa gekommen ist weggenommen wird
uneinig sind sich die EU-Länder
weiterhin darüber wie man den
Einkaufspreis für Gasimporte senken kann
15 Länder fordern einen preisdeckel
alles auf Spekulationen die Kosten der
Gasproduktion sind nicht gestiegen aber
die Preise das trifft unsere Wirtschaft
und Bürger wir brauchen jetzt eine klare
Botschaft
andere Läden es ab den Preis zu deckeln
fürchten Versorgungsengpässe
bei allen diesen ich habe in allen
diesen Vorschlägen keine Sicherheit
gesehen wie garantiert wird dass unsere
Lieferpartner weiter nach Europa
ausreichend Gas liefern wenn wir nicht
mehr bereit sind den verlangten Preis zu
zahlen die Diskussion darüber wie der
Gaspreis gesenkt werden kann wird Europa
weiter beschäftigen
in Deutschland beschloss der Bundestag
wegen der Energiekrise heute die Senkung
der Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas und Fernwärme
von 19 auf 7%. das ganze gilt ab Oktober
bis Ende März 2024 der Bundesverband der
Energie- und Wasserwirtschaft betonte
dass die Versorger die Steuerentlastung
an die Kunden weitergeben werden
der Arbeitsmarkt zeigt sich trotz der
kriselnden Wirtschaft weiter recht
stabil mit dem Ende der Sommerferien und
dem Start des neuen Ausbildungsjahres
sank die Zahl der Arbeitslosen leicht im
September waren zwei Millionen
486.000 Menschen ohne Arbeit
62.000 weniger als im August die Quote
liegt bei 5,4 Prozent im Vergleich zum
Vorjahresmonat ist die Zahl der
Arbeitslosen um 21.000 gestiegen was die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit auch mit der
Erfassung der ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
erklärt
die Zufriedenheit mit der Ampelkoalition
ist laut ZDF Politbarometer deutlich
gesunken knapp die Hälfte der Befragten
sagt die Bundesregierung mache ihre
Arbeit eher gut
44% beurteilen sie eher schlecht im März
waren noch drei Viertel der Befragten
mit der Ampel zufrieden wenn am Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre würden SPD cdu/csu
und Grüne je einen Prozentpunkt
verlieren
FDP und AFD ein hinzugewinnen die Linke
Liebe unverändert
und das ganze Politbarometer gibt es wie
immer am heute journal um 22 Uhr und
jederzeit in unserer heute App
die corona-zahlen steigen wieder
deutlich an Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach und das robert-koch-
und winterwelle Deutschland sei aber
besser vorbereitet als vergangenen
Herbst so Lauterbach von morgen an gilt
das neue Infektionsschutzgesetz der
Minister forderte die Länder auf die
Maßnahmen die es biete auch umzusetzen
zum Beispiel die maskenpflicht
Innenräumen
andernfalls drohten personelle Engpässe
in der kritischen Infrastruktur
vor rund zwei Monaten schockierte das
massive Fischsterben in der oder die
Öffentlichkeit jetzt haben deutsche
Fachleute bestätigt der Auslöser war vor
allem ein stark überhöhter Salzgehalt in
dem salzigen Wasser habe sich eine
giftige Algenart stark vermehrt was zur
massenhaften Tod der Fische führte so
der Abschlussbericht für das
Bundesumweltministerium der Bericht
lässt offen wie Salz und weitere
Schadstoffe in die oder kamen in Polen
ermittelt dazu noch die
Staatsanwaltschaft
Brasilien steht vor einer
Richtungsentscheidung am Sonntag wird
gewählt nach vier Jahren unter Präsident
boysonaro
einem Mann der extremen Rechten der
corona-verharmloste die Abholzung des
Regenwaldes erleichterte Waffengesetze
lockerte sein Herausforderer der linke
Ex-Präsident Lula das Silva er liegt in
Umfragen deutlich vorn und steht nach
einer aufgehobenen Gefängnisstrafe vor
einem Comeback aus einem tiefgespaltenen
Land berichtet Christoph röckerath zum
Gruppenbild der sieben Kandidaten
funktioniert das Protokoll noch doch
dann eskaliert die letzte Debatte vor
der Wahl schnell vor allem zwischen
Präsident bolsonaro und seinem
Herausforderer Ex-Präsident Lula
sie haben gar nichts gegen meine
Regierung in der Hand hören Sie auf zu
lügen und schämen sie sich Lula
es ist doch verrückt dass der Präsident
der Republik hier erscheint und schamlos
irgendwelche Dinge von sich gibt herr
Präsident wenn Sie hier erscheinen Lügen
Sie bitte weniger Mieter Mensch die
Debatte ist von Unsachlichkeit geprägt
beraten von einem seiner Söhne
verbreitet bolzenaru Anschuldigungen von
denen viele seit Jahren als unwahr
widerlegt sind
die Regierung Lula war der Kopf einer
großen Bande es ist eine Regierung die
die gender Ideologie aufzwingen will und
sie wollen Kindern in der Schule
beibringen sich verfrüht für Sex zu
interessieren
das Echo der Öffentlichkeit des kritisch
im von Ungleichheit und Armut geprägten
Land wünschen sich viele Brasilianer
mehr Sachlichkeit
es ging für sie nur darum ihre Gegner
anzugreifen anstatt Vorschläge zu
unterbreiten
das Ego der Kandidaten steht einer
sachlichen diskussionssymbole des Landes
im Weg
Präsident bolzenario beschwört den
Kulturkampf spricht gar von einer Wahl
zwischen Gut und Böse doch glaubt man in
übereinstimmenden Umfragen ist die
Mehrheit der Brasilianer des Streitens
müde und setzt er auf die
sozialpolitische Agenda Lulas
geht wählen steht auf dem Plakat sollte
am Sonntag kein Kandidat über 50% kommen
entscheidet vier Wochen später eine
Stichwahl
dies könnte der tödlichste Hurrikan in
der Geschichte Florida sein das sagte
US-Präsident Joe Biden noch ist das
ganze Ausmaß der Katastrophe nicht zu
überschauen Trümmer Zerstörung
Überschwemmung lässt der monstersturm
Ian zurück nun erreicht dabei die
nächste Küste in South Carolina Ulrike
rödle berichtet
Wilma Jeans zurückgekommen um zu sehen
was von ihrem Haus übrig geblieben ist
am Mittwoch traf Hurricane hier an Land
das haben wir vorgefunden wir wohnen
seit sechs Monaten hier damals habe ich
unser Erspartes genommen um das Haus zu
kaufen zum Glück habe ich eine Familie
die mir hilft das zu retten was noch zu
retten ist
Hurricane hat die Küstenregion Floridas
schwer getroffen mehr als 2,5 Millionen
Haushalte sind ohne Strom bisher sollen
mindestens 21 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen sein doch die Behörden
befürchten dass es noch viel mehr sind
besonders schlimm sind die Wassermassen
die Helfer kommen nur langsam voran
der Gouverneur von Florida wendet sich
am Morgen an die Einwohner
sie haben viel verstörende Bilder
gesehen von Häusern die im Wasser
versunken sind der Hurrikan Ian hat im
Süden Floridas sehr viel zerstört aber
sogar im Landesinneren hat er vieles
kaputt gemacht und die Helfer werden nun
dort im Einsatz sein
die Regierung in Washington verspricht
nun noch mehr Hilfe und Präsident beiden
richtet sich an die Bevölkerung
mein Herz ist bei all denen die vom
Hurrikan ihren betroffen sind es ist
vielleicht das Schlimmste Hurrikan in
der Geschichte von Florida
mittlerweile ist Hurricane ihren
weitergezogen und die Menschen in South
Carolina bereiten sich vor die ersten
Vorboten haben den Bundesstaat bereits
erreicht
kommen wir jetzt zum Sport die
Fußballfrauen des FC Bayern München
feiern ein schöner Tag ja große Freude
über das Erreichen der Champions League
die Fußballfrauen des FC Bayern München
besiegten San Sebastian aus Spanien
überlegen mit 3:1 schon das Hinspiel
hatten die Münchnerinnen mit 1:0
gewonnen jetzt können Sie sich wie
gesagt auf die Gruppenphase der
Champions League freuen die am 19
oktober beginnt
weißblaue Glückseligkeit bei den Frauen
in rot denn bayern hätte sogar nur eine
Halbzeit zum Erfolg gereicht in der 18
Minute zeigen Linda Dallmann und Sydney
Lohmann wie klassisches Doppelpassspiel
funktioniert da man mit dem 1:0 der
erste Schritt ist gemacht Bayern bleibt
druckvoll wieder Linda Dahlmann die den
Ball nach innen spielen will doch der
wird abgefälscht von der ehemaligen
Münchnerin Specht und schon steht es 2:0
23 Minuten auch das 3:0 über die rechte
Seite Sydney Lohmann auf Lea Schiller 43
Minute Ergebnis bayerischer Dominanz
kurz vor dem Pausenpfiff das 3:1 dabei
bleibt Champions League Qualifikation
geschafft
als Kölns torggerannt Anthony modeste
kurzfristig den Verein verließ um in
Dortmund für den schwer erkrankten
Sebastian aller einzuspringen war die
Empörung der FC Fans groß morgen kommt
es zum Wiedersehen in der Bundesliga
wenn Dortmund in Köln Antrieb ihren
einstigen Lieblings derart ausgelassen
in einem Dortmunder trikotjubeln zu
sehen schmerzt jeden Kölner Fan sein
ehemaliger Trainer setzt sich dennoch
für einen freundlichen Empfang für ihn
und den zweiten Abwanderer Ötscher an
allen ich hoffe dass keiner vergisst
dass die Jungs sehr sehr lange und viel
für den FC getan haben und
hoffe dass sie vernünftig begrüßt werden
so wie sich das aus meiner Sicht gehört
deeskalierend mag da wirken das modest
nicht als strahlender Held anreist nur
ein Türchen gelang im bislang sein neuer
Trainer muss in stark reden wie Toni
sich jetzt in den letzten Wochen hier
präsentiert hatte sehen wir ihn auf
einem sehr guten Weg dennoch steht ihm
ein schwerer Gang bevor nach Köln
ja und wie es ihm da ergangen ist morgen
im Aktuellen Sportstudio ja danke schön
Rudi finde ich und regnerisch wird das
Wochenende mehr sonnige Lichtblicke
bietet der Feiertag genaueres gleich von
Katja horneffer das heute journal können
Sie in diesem Abend um 22 Uhr sehen mit
Christian Sievers und Morgen begrüßt Sie
hier mit riserin bis bald
[Musik]
guten Abend auch in der vergangenen
Nacht hatte sich wieder Nebel gebildet
der sich in den Vormittagsstunden dann
auflöstet dann gab es Quellwolken und
über dem Ärmelkanal rauscht bereits das
stürmische tieffall Burger heran das
bringt Regen mit und dieser Regen
breitet sich heute Nacht weiter auswärts
aus bis zum Morgen erreicht der Fehmarn
und das Breisgau im Osten ist es dagegen
zum Teil klar da sinken die Temperaturen
auf 6 bis 2 Grad unter den Regenwolken
bleibt es bei 11 bis 7 Grad milder und
morgen zieht der Regen weiter ostwärts
schon mittags erreicht er die oder die
Neiße und das Berchtesgadener Land
dahinter lockern die Wolken auf es
entwickelt sich kräftige Regenschauer
zum Teil auch Gewitter sie müssen mit
stürmischen Böden rechnen vor allen
Dingen über den Mittelgebirgen wenn es
länger regnet bleibt es auch kühl dann
steigen die Temperaturen nur so auf 11
bis 14 oder 15 Grad 16 bis 17 Grad sind
es dagegen hier zwischen der Weser und
dem Niederrhein am Sonntag kann es dann
noch kräftig regnen in Süddeutschland ab
Montag aber setzt sich von Westen
Hochdruck Einfluss durch das bedeutet
nicht nur strahlende Sonnenschein
sondern auch mal Nebel und Hochnebel bei
Temperaturen bis 20 Grad am Dienstag
guten Abend